two two two
two two two
two two
two two i feel like i've always had to
leave somewhere
to become what i need to be
a lot of people who make things don't
feel like they belong
japan's the most alien place i've been
in the world
it's so hard to communicate here
the beauty of dance is a physical
language that everyone understands
i think maybe the japanese got my work
before i did
i was born and brought up on a farm in
scotland
i started studying house at the age of
four the animals didn't really
appreciate my dancing
i couldn't participate supported the
trail because i was so self-conscious
about the shapes i was making
i guess my survival technique was to
dance i was
sent to the royal ballet school i
remember the journey with my mom and my
brother
really not wanting to go and wondering
why i was being
made to be
i didn't fit in
and that led me to contemporary dance
joining valley rumba
people can't see beyond princes and
swans
i wanted to make something that was more
relevant to everyone
i come from the background of pong
many of my friends only express
themselves through their clothes
and i wanted to embrace that
i'm fascinated by what's acceptable
but more isn't acceptable
[Music]
i established my own rules in order to
break them
but i'm changing
i'm lucky to still be alive
when do you know you finish something
and you know it's complete
well i'm still trying to master
stillness
i'm not running away from something
i'm constantly going somewhere on the
journey
i can't imagine stopping
where are we going
you